[Music]
what's up guys today is gonna be a super
fun video I've been seeing a lot of
people do sensory deprivation tanks
which is basically just a soundproof
light proof tank with water in it that
you can float on so it's basically just
like meditation but the only problem is
they're pretty expensive and they're
always booked up so I thought why not
make my own so I'm go to my friend
Marlins place right now he's the
youtuber he does those crazy gummy
videos and other DIY stuff so I really
think he could help have you heard of a
sensory deprivation tank no what is it's
like the Dead Sea basically oh you float
let's make it we could do it yeah you
know what that is
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah you want to help us yeah Mike so we
saw okay great we go I gots all right
here bang bang soft yes we need a pool I
got a pool a little dirty though but you
don't think we need to clean that I mean
its water its water this works you guys
are gonna go take another dimension
there's a professional youtuber we're
gonna do the YouTube quick change into
my shorts oh you ready all right there
we go okay we got to do that
is up something we haven't perfected it
yet here we go
this isn't work this is our fish I just
changed in just a bit quick time's
running out will speed this up right oh
my socks
alright sensory deprivation tank time go
really alone you guys sure you don't
want to join me
yeah I'm good for right now but uh yeah
I'm good too yeah all right
oh my god it is so cool yeah I'm gonna
lay down and then you guys will assault
me and I'm gonna float up why is
something me so the water after salting
the water for 30 minutes it was time to
test it out
[Music]
I'm not floating it's not working I'm
gonna give up yeah this that's not
something up it off if you watch
stranger things you don't eat 1,500
pounds of salt are you sure it worked in
the show yes 11:00 went to another
division that we're getting 1500 pounds
of Saia
so I'm gonna call Costco see how much
1,500 pounds of absence I lost in an ad
what salt yeah we have how much my
budget for this video is $300 I guess
the video is over here because I can't
spend it dude I got I got a magician
friend he's made like Ferraris appear so
like I don't get why he can just make
1,500 pounds of salt appear so your
magician friend could make all of our
some salt appear right now yet she was
on Ellen so the magicians name is Daniel
Fernandez and he really was on Ellen so
there's still hope all right yeah so my
friends right here just texted me I need
just make you walk on water I couldn't
believe that I just walked on water but
I was even more excited that I just got
an awesome thumbnail and title we still
needed Daniel to make the salt appear
one to breathe in
[Music]
yeah he kept doing tricks that had
nothing to do with salt but they were
really cool so I'm not complaining I
reminded Daniel for the third time that
we need him to make salt appear so he
told us he would turn our cash into salt
close your eyes as a way to concentrate
[Music]
all right so the magician stole our
money but it's okay because he did some
cool tricks do some math like we have
three brains right here exactly how much
salt we need and what we need to flow
out to the dope montage done
what guys didn't do anything but I
actually figured it out here's what we
got to do you guys ready the pool holds
a thousand liters and I googled the Dead
Sea which is what we're trying to
replicate and the Dead Sea has one point
two four kilograms of salt per liter 250
kilograms to make this 11 and see now
that's still expensive because I don't
know 50 pounds and convert it might be
practical and I only feel the pool to
500 meters me 275 pounds of salt does
this make sense we went to the store
well rolled to the store grab the salt a
lot of it actually and rolled out in
style we then have to carry all the bags
up to the roof which was really hard
because they were each 40-pound I guess
that's not that much but it was really
heavy we also had to carry pots of
boiling water to the roof because I
realized I needed warm water for the
salt to dissolve we poured the water
into the pool and started filling it
with salt it felt like we were in a
scene from an epic Italian mobster movie
[Music]
after four hours of mixing and waiting
it was time to test it out oh I couldn't
believe that it worked it was amazing I
was so relaxed I felt like I was flying
my mind went blank
I was totally free so free that IP dolan
the video wasn't over yet though to make
it a real sensory deprivation tank I
needed to make it sound proof and light
proof so I covered myself with a blanket
[Music]
and then I went to another dimension
guys I disappeared I'm doing this
voiceover from the upside down right now
I'm chilling with 11 it 11 say hi yes
that's right I'm hanging out with V 11
right now in the upside down because of
a DIY sensory deprivation tank that I
made it was totally worth it you guys
should totally do it I had a blast
thanks to Marlin and Austin make sure to
check their links down below I'll see
you guys in the next video all right how
do I get back 11 where'd you go guys
Oh No
[Music]